it will feel even better to talk about
football once we know that the nfl and
the nfl players association have an
agreement that will allow for the
players to feel good about showing up at
work and feel good about the financial
side of things but there is one reality
we've seen it play out in other sports
where players choose as a matter of
their own personal health their concern
about family members or just their level
of comfort trying to play football or
any other sport in a pandemic they
choose to not play the nfl chris has
proposed a procedure for opting out for
all of the 2020 season now
the league wants a fairly short time
frame for players to make their
decisions august 1 is the deadline for
the team to receive written notice that
a player is going to opt out and once
the player opts out
it is irrevocable for 10 20. you can't
change your mind you can't have an
epiphany you can't make a decision based
upon how the pandemic may be turning the
right way come halloween and you'd like
to finish the season with your team yeah
once you are team that's five and oh and
ready yeah right go go ahead or just or
just or just divide yeah the virus but
the testing is better yeah they've
they've developed a test that turns it
around in an hour and the hot spots that
currently are raging are no longer hot
spots and guys feel better about it and
and uh too late and here's the thing if
you opt out you can't play for anybody
you can be traded you can be cut but you
can't play for anyone in 2020 if now
this is the nfl's proposal the the my
ass why different rules let me ask you
that like why why do that like what what
if a guy like demarcus lawrence right
he's one of the better players in our
sport we know that he's thinking about
this right now like why why if he wanted
to come back in the middle of october
and things were better do they just feel
like too many guys might do that is that
what they're doing there i don't even
understand
what's the logic there i i think they're
trying to keep as few guys as possible
from opting out you create a short time
frame you make it completely irrevocable
where you don't get you know two strikes
or three strikes or a chance to you know
what if a guy's just not comfortable
what if a guy gets to the middle of
august and says you know i've been here
for a few weeks now we've been doing
this and boy i really do i i want to see
how i feel after i play a game yeah
right maybe i'm not going to feel all
that comfortable about this after
playing a game no they want guys to have
to make an early decision and the
earlier the decision the less likely
guys will opt out especially if it is
irrevocable now
there is one interesting twist here
because you've got some guys that would
like to get paid like a dalvin cook of
the minnesota vikings yeah quit their
off-season workout program and indicated
maybe a willingness to hold out
you you can use
the implicit threat or not even
necessarily implicit you can you can
you can
say to the team hey you know i i already
don't feel good about what i'm getting
paid you throw this pandemic on top of
it
i'm underpaid as it is i don't want to
take on the additional risks i'm
thinking about exercising my
option to opt out
and uh you can change my mind
there's a way that you can change my
mind right now that's a hell of a gamble
you talk about an all-in move because if
the team says sorry we're not doing
anything we're calling your bluff then
to save face you have to just give up
the whole season that that would be
problematic for the player who makes
that threat and the team doesn't blink
then the player just sits out the whole
year but from the team's perspective do
you want to play with fire like that if
you're the vikings do you want to run
the risk of dalvin cook opting out even
if he regrets it once he's done it it's
done there isn't damn thing he or anyone
else can do about it no no you're right
that's i mean that's where i would you
know my advice to a player like that
would be you know make sure that you're
really ready to sit out and not do it
you know make sure that okay you don't
really want to play this year because
you don't feel comfortable about your
contract situation and covet 19 and
where that's going you know be be
comfortable with that and then okay
if you're comfortable with that decision
and now you get a contract offer or
something that goes okay well that i i
can't deny that right there i'm going
for it then that's that's one thing but
here's another thing for you mike you
know i guess two things that just have
kind of popped up to me that i'm curious
about first off like i understand the
august first like thought process of the
deadline you know they want to know what
the teams are going to look like right
teams also want to know like oh if he's
of our second receiver if you're the
houston texans and all of a sudden you
know some player there let's say brandon
cooks isn't comfortable
they got to figure out a way to fill
that void so they don't want to be
caught you know i think you know just
totally by surprise here you know in the
middle of august or something like that
but i don't know how the nfl can give a
hard deadline of august 1st right now
when nothing's agreed on right i mean
that can't be real you can't be but that
would be that's part of the agreement it
will be the opposite will be part of it
right okay they're proposing an opt-out
right up until august 1. so they reach
an agreement one of the facets of the
agreement is that players have opt-out
rights until august 1. but again it's
not enough time it's not enough of an
opportunity it's not a player to get to
the point where he feels comfortable or
not comfortable with what's going on
because here's the thing he doesn't know
anything yet how do you know the
procedures that are going to be done to
feel comfortable or not comfortable
that's where i would just be like i
don't know how this is going to go so
how do you expect me to know by august
1st if i don't know what the hell you're
going to do to keep us safe on a daily
basis
and and here's the problem and let me
just give you a basic example as it
relates to a signing bonus you get a a
10 million dollar signing bonus on a
five-year contract so it's two million
per year that you earn back in signing
bonus money you're in the second year of
the contract
uh you get to the middle of august and
you just say i can't do this i can't do
it i didn't realize before august 1 that
i was going to feel this way but i just
can't do it i can't play this year if
you quit then if you opt out then right
you got to pay back 2 million
in signing bonus money if you opt out
before august 1 you don't have to pay
back the signing bonus money as long as
you fully comply with all terms of your
contract next year there's a lot of
there's a lot of fine print as to what
you have to do next year if you opt out
this year but the bottom line is if you
do everything you're supposed to do you
don't have to pay back bonus money if
you opt out but if you get to a point
where you just can't do it anymore and
you walk off the job they have every
right to come get that two million
dollars back from you so that that it
makes it a very high stakes decision it
does you're giving up your salary
there's a there's an opportunity to have
a stipend but when you look at the fine
print there like if you've already
gotten a signing bonus or if you've
already gotten a roster bonus you've
already gotten payments this year that
counts against the stipend and i think
it's 150 or 250 000 it's gone quickly
it's 150 000 right and uh um you you you
you get that 150 000 eating away at very
quickly if you've gotten other payments
already so it's not a whole lot of money
and also it counts against your salary
next year too so it's not free money
either it's just a little something to
tide you over for the 2020 season until
next year when you have to earn that
money back but uh look this is not an
ideal
solution for giving players a meaningful
opportunity to opt out chris and i hope
they do tweak it a little bit and i hope
they do expand it a little bit and i
hope they give guys a chance to show up
and practice and feel
feel
safe or not safe how do you know by
august 1. right training camp opens july
28th right how do you know if you truly
feel safe in just a couple of days they
need to delay that and maybe they need
to give a guy one strike one opportunity
i can leave one time and change my mind
and come back second time i think that's
there then it's irrevocable i don't like
the idea that it's that it's speak now
forever hold you yeah i agree that's
what i was gonna say too i don't like
that you know i mean what do you mean
you're gonna tell human beings about
their life like maybe three weeks into
august where they don't feel comfortable
and maybe there's been a few guys on the
team that have gotten covered 19 and
they just don't like the outlook of
things
you know i i don't i think it is a
little too you know i don't want to i'm
for lack of a better phrase inhumane or
just not nice or whatever you want to
say you know this is these are
unforeseen times and and circumstances
that we're going through right now so
you know one first off the august first
thing needs to be backed up because no
player can make a logical decision
without knowing logically what the hell
the protocols are yet so that that has
to be bumped back a little bit and i'm
with you i think there should be a
little leeway maybe into like hey
you can come to training camp and within
the first two weeks
we'll let you make a decision on whether
you think you want to ride this out or
not uh but you know i don't necessarily
like that like oh now you're gonna have
to pay back 2 million let alone you're
not going to make the 2 million you're
making this year you know that's that's
a very hard line stance for a bunch of
guys who are sitting pretty with lots of
cash in their pockets
i have a feeling this is an issue that's
going to come up again and again until
they get it all hammered out and when
they do get it hammered out we'll
probably have some thoughts on what the
final opt-out rules are because i have a
feeling that at the end of the day there
will be some issues there will be some
twists there will be some problems with
the final protocols whatever they may be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports